so Brad darling houses here [ __ ] was
recently on and he said what's going to
define crypto assets in 2020 is the
utility value we're on that curve
between a store of well something that
you just hold in the price goes up
versus actually something that you can
use is Bitcoin because a lot of the
criticisms that I read want its energy
intensive it uses a lot of energy and to
in terms of transaction speeds it's
really slow yes so first when it comes
to the energy consumption Bitcoin is
using majority renewable energy right
people are having input into that
business a cost that is the energy cost
and so what they're actually doing is
they're going to find the lowest cost
energy which happens to be renewable so
we see things like gas flaring
waste-to-energy geothermal hydroelectric
etc so I think that's actually driving a
lot of innovation and if you go to China
I mean that's cold fuel they are fossil
fuel fueled energy yes there's
definitely some not renewable energy but
there's many studies that have now come
public where sixty seventy eighty
percent of the energy consumption is
actually renewable energy in total in
total yeah absolutely and then when it
comes to utility I'm a transaction side
last year the adjusted transaction
volume on chain so this is not exchange
traded volume or anything like that
actually people sending it for one
purpose or another was was over half a
trillion dollars and so what that means
is it's bigger than venmo Apple pay
PayPal etc in terms of transaction
volumes and so you're not doing it too
often I guess the point well so again
people can complain about transaction
speeds cost etc but the end of the day
people are using this more than they're
using venmo Apple pay and PayPal as a
store of wealth though it's the biggest
argument here for Bitcoin the store
Wow it definitely serves a purpose as a
store of wealth we've seen that do very
well it's up 30 percent this year it's
up 150% over the last twelve months well
people are also using it to transact and
send it for one purpose or another to
either businesses or to other
individuals Warren Buffett very
dismissive yesterday he said shorting
suitcases ie you know people laundering
money perhaps they're not gonna use
suitcases anymore they're gonna use
things like digital assets Bitcoin
specifically so my two things with
Warren first of all somebody should tell
them that Wells Fargo one of
companies in his portfolio recently was
found guilty of helping the Sonoma
cartel launder a lot of money so I don't
know that so proof on anything else but
obviously things like that with Wells
Fargo have been a concern and the second
thing is I don't really take technology
advice from somebody who uses a flip
phone or doesn't use email right again
you shouldn't ask me for value investing
advice and so he kind of has his domain
which he's the best doesn't get it so
stay out of it basically people will
listen to his opinion because he's one
of the best investors of all time when
it comes to technology though I think
there's better people to listen to thing
he's done because seriously talk to me
about Sweden but yes they've launched a
digital coil it's they're testing the
testing phases they are way more
advanced it seems than then even the
Chinese who are clearly pumping a lot of
money in investment yes so these central
back digital currencies are all coming
and really what I think people need to
understand is all of the central BEC
digital currencies are simply taking the
existing monetary policy and changing
the technology form-factor
right what bitcoin does is it actually
is a different monetary policy it's not
a Fiat inflationary type model and so
ultimately we're gonna have is a
competition of currencies but it's not
gonna be a competition on technology
won't be are they digital are they not
everything will be digital instead what
we're gonna have is a competition of
monetary policy that's I think where we
believe that the Bitcoin monetary policy
is superior to central bank monetary
policies and ultimately Bitcoin will be
the winner and will be the next global
reserve currency at some point in the
future we're gonna continue this
conversation there's always more to
discuss you're a hundred thousand core
by 2021 and we're going to come back to
that energy the renewables I'm going to
do some digging see populonia there
thank you so much for joining us in the
show or